let's talk about this ukraine stuff
let's jump into the story we got this
from washington examiner youtube flags
oliver stone's latest ukraine
documentary now i don't know when this
came out there's a trailer for it's a
2016 documentary ukraine on fire by
oliver stone they put this warning on it
age restricting it now there's a lot of
tweets here we got this one from rumble
they say youtube removed the documentary
ukraine fire we believe the public
should decide what it sees not google
execs we're proud to announce the
producers uploaded the film to rumble
enabling anyone who wishes to view it
well i don't think it's taken down but
they are they've also they've also
flagged like trailers and people have
started uploading this
in mass to youtube so if you search for
it now you can see like a bunch of new
uploads of this documentary
and it basically talks about there's
like this uh weird dry sand effect yeah
there's like a leaked phone call of
victoria nuland talking about who the
like the president of ukraine's going to
be i think you were mentioning that
right yeah yeah
she was uh had had some pics on who she
wanted to install and then it happened
right is that what it was oh yeah the
crazy thing is you guys see that story
about like the bio labs and all that
stuff
yeah we were talking about before
earlier uh before we but yeah like she
they were rubio was like grilling her
and then she's like she kind of was
sheepishly like um yeah we're worried
about the
the bio labs might fall in the hands of
the if you like what was that
if you go to uh the us us embassy of
like the u.s embassy in ukraine's the
actual.gov website it says the u.s built
two bio labs level two
specifically for
food safety and consumer protection but
then it makes like it talks about how
they're like researching pathogens and
stuff
so i certainly think the idea is a bit
of gain of function how many i don't
know about that that's that's the thing
right so if russia comes out and they're
like they're doing data function in
ukraine i'm like that's how the fact
checkers are able to dismiss this
because what we all we know is that the
website and the us government said like
oh there's pathogens here it could just
be like they're researching
like they're they're trying they claim
it's the biological threat reduction
program to make sure people don't get
sick or something
reducing botulism
well that's a toxin i mean right or is
it it's a fungus or something how many
um bio labs does ukraine have in america
uh sixty four four four uh four hundred
twenty twenty and six point six percent
i have no idea yeah he was danny was
just showing us some wild stuff before
of the the old videos of uh oh yeah
zelinski doing the roman salute that's a
nice pretty crazy yeah so well mostly
joking about how he's like we sure have
a lot of nazis here and everybody's like
yeah yeah yeah
it's one of those but then i thought
even crazier it's like oh you know
obama's government we're going to have
to we're going to join nato but
obviously as their puppet and everyone's
like it's funny because it's true this
is the ukrainian president before he was
president yeah when he was just a
comedian the conspiracy theory is that
he's a comedian who played the the
ukrainian president on the tv show
and so they asked him to actually do it
because they knew that he could act
right or or he's like well i mean it's
not really a conspiracy theory that's
kind of what happened but his approval
rating was like super low before this i
really i was doing something like my oh
actually my mom was saying it's like
less than twenty percent how many mine
levels how many people's approval rating
right now is skyrocketing because of war
talk
that's my secret that's the secret
ingredient yeah i know you're getting
them just dude it's legitimately imagine
you have a girlfriend and you guys hate
each other and she's like you're the
worst i'm gonna break up and then
someone comes into the house and you
have to fight the mob and then exactly
and the movie always they you know what
you you're not so bad now i realize why
i loved you in the first place you know
i'll let you in on a a i was reading
this thing
and it said that
you can use men can use fear to simulate
attraction so like what you're saying is
turn the lights off no no they they say
like if you want to go on a date bring
them to a rickety bridge oh wow yeah for
real crack your knuckles a lot of first
date
hey listen i have a nice night plan for
you and sort of drive out to the middle
of the forest pretend the engine broke
down yeah
there was an actual stereo playing some
squeaky sound find a knife stuff like
that she can't be scared of you is this
blood on the hood crazy yes are you
scared no there was there was actually
an article that claimed that that if
like it's true if you bring them to a
high location like the observatory of
like the sears tower or something
observation deck or you like bring them
over to those bridges where the floor is
glass it'll make their hearts beat
faster and faster you want to trigger a
flight response no for real that's what
they claimed i think bring them out into
the middle of a lake on a canoe and then
sort of oh yes so what's it going to
well that's it's always sunny the
implication that's the dinner what is
that the dentist is that the dentist
no that wasn't the dentist the
implication of the the yeah he was like
you bring him out on a boat to the
middle of the lake or the ocean and then
you know because of the implication
they're like what implications you know
like
you're on a boat no but that there's
like um i'll tell you this for that
stuff i mean that's why you pay a guy to
come you know show up and be like give
me all your money and then you yeah
karate chop them off yeah or you like
you know if you're dating a blind chick
you can just you can do the whole thing
yourself yeah you know you can be like
i'm generally dating a blind chick
but uh uh the crazy thing about this
idea is like imagine this like you're
you're making a joke about how some dude
might bring a woman out to the middle of
nowhere on a rickety bridge because he's
trying to manipulate her but think about
a guy who's dumb enough to actually do
that and it works out and he has no idea
what's going on you know what i mean
yeah he doesn't put two and two together
like why that work he just goes yeah so
then it works out for him and then he
ends up marrying this woman and then
there's the dude who's like i planned
that and y'all hate me for it it's like
if so if you're conscious of what you're
doing to manipulate you're a really bad
person everything's gross well i mean
everything that's like a human rule that
you're saying the same as
um when you watch cuteness or any sort
of thing like that as soon as you know
like when you're watching a baby being
cute it's okay but then as soon as
someone's doing it on purpose where you
go i know it's cute when i kind of do
this and they always do it it's like ugh
it's gross let's test that someone gave
me a pacifier yeah no nope not cute
that wouldn't be cute if you did it on
an accident well anything anything's
anything conscious is far more
disgusting true yeah i was just looking
up oxytocin it looks like oxytocin is
not only the the love chemical but also
can make people feel extreme negative
feelings too this is from the huffington
post i don't know how much research has
been done into this
probably none maybe this is part of why
putting people in scary situations what
does the huffington post think about um
tim's date plan of bringing them into
the middle of the forest pretty good
no no the dennis system to get them
dripping
what is what was it
i know you here's how about this one you
bring him into the house and then you
say you have to go to the bathroom and
then you run out to the car and come
back in a scream mask
and you sort of
you go out and then the actual idea was
to bring them to a scary movie yeah you
know yeah it was like invite him in a
day and then bring him to movies and go
see a horror film well yeah or turn up
if you want to dial up that would be a
good plan in the 70s yeah right that's
boring yeah now you got to do it like
michael jackson didn't thriller and like
be a werewolf like actually threatened
and scare him like augmented reality
glasses
no i'm kidding you can always offer a
pair of glasses when they come over or
hire a team of hackers to do cyber
warfare on your bank accounts while
you're there oh did you imagine that if
some guy like you hire a team maybe this
is a good skit or a bit a guy hires like
10 people and he tries convincing his
date that he's you know special agent
yeah and it's like the russians have
come for him because he's got
information about the war or something
you have your keyboards and she goes
those aren't hooked up to anyone he goes
they're new stuff
all your boys like right when the check
comes all the guys come and they go yeah
we gotta go we gotta we gotta go you go
no you're like no at least before you're
like you like fight your way out of this
restaurant
and then you're like quick get in the
car if you wanna live you'll come with
me and she like screams and punches you
in the ball in the trunk yeah you're
getting in the trunk
that's the tinder swindler too
tinder swindler wasn't that guy just
like if you're listening and you're
looking for dating tips
hey ryan pop him in the trunk
what the what i said ryan you got him
all day the tinder swindler do you i
don't know if you heard but i swindled
the tinder swindler did you who well he
does cameos and it's uh 300 bucks but
it's like a thousand bucks if you want
it for promotional purposes but then i
weaseled my not promotional purposes
but you actually hired me i got him he
goes oh congrats on you're special and
do not like well that's been my favorite
thing with the tinder swindler is that
he his whole thing was to his girlfriend
it's always goes my enemies are after me
right yeah so i've been loving saying
that to everyone like my chick or
whatever it's like baby oh you have to
get the food my enemies are after me you
don't understand i can't be home by 10
my enemies are after me so this you
could be you could be definitely saying
that like oh hey the stream was late but
you know our enemies are after us over
here
this is the first one actually yeah we
got off yeah
but but like while the show's going and
we're like oh guys we're sorry we
charged you double for the the premium
content this week our enemies are books
how many how many times you need to be
swatted before they show up and you go
just grab a seat let's interview you
yeah we're gonna have food waiting for
me oh yeah i actually was like should we
just get like a thing of doughnuts yeah
and you know and it's like for sale some
people were like maybe donuts is just
too offensive throw them at the cops
that that's like more like they're like
beef jerky i think yeah or or you know
just like coffee cake yeah something
that's sealed so they're not like what's
in this poison yeah homemade cheesecake
there you go what is this the first i've
heard of the tinder swindler this is a
really never heard of the tinder
swindler crazy
february 22nd documentary on netflix
what is it you must know this is the
brief run yeah he was like ripping women
off yeah you're in the know he really
isn't i was actually on tinder he leaves
the show and goes right back into the
bunker
what's that he's like a con artist and
he just conned all these women oh my
gosh he's just getting like free food
and stuff though right no no he this one
when we gave him like uh she took out
all these credit cards and gave him 250
thousands
he's got a lot and the thing is the move
the movie had three women in it which
means there were 50 that didn't want to
come forward so how how do you how do
you fall for this stuff well that's how
you get them you get them scared that
all their money's gone and then boom
you're in what's the best the main way
yeah she's scared we've been through
this
instead of bringing them out to the
bridge you bring them out to a
metaphorical bridge where their money is
all disappearing right well he tricked
them into thinking he was a billionaire
that was the big thing is like these
girls the first date he'd be like you
know what meet me at the airport and
then go fly on a private jet to
switzerland for a night at a hotel but
that's still expensive yes because it
was a ponzi scheme that was being funded
by all the other women who were paying
for this one thing and then she would
now be paying for him to do this to
somebody else but were these women rich
or something no but he just knows
girls
he was sort of involved in the thing too
where he would get the girls for example
he would write them uh fake employment
letters for his fake company so then
they can now go get their lines of
credits extended he was pretty involved
in the procedure he had it down to
pretty decent science and these women
didn't know what they were doing it
wasn't that it's like i mean you know
you got some cash like if people were
like hey can you lend me a thousand
bucks obviously i'm good for it why
would anyone believe that you wouldn't
be right especially if they kind of have
oh if i ask someone for money no if they
asked you yeah if you asked that yeah
yeah like if you asked me for a decent
amount of money yeah i kind of get like
you know my enemies are after me i
wouldn't think anything else can i can i
have 400 bucks right yeah you know i got
it well yeah you got yours well that's
the thing you just found out that i have
more money than you know
uh no more tinder swindlers from new
york post dating app ads background
checks here we go here we go
so get it back whenever you can here we
go everybody so this is
not only did we get uh danny and ryan to
come out here and do the show we don't
pay them yeah i actually just got him to
give me 400 what he doesn't realize is
that i just put the terms at 50 interest
per minute
the juice is running
if you'd like to close up the loan if
not your companion i never signed up
never caught an honest john
trouble makers
okay so yeah you guys are gonna be like
deer hunter later tonight just
russian roulette yep what red red
headbands at the end it's his birthday
you can have the money back if you want
if those dollars are really made a cop
give me 400 bucks for my birthday are
they yeah are they worth less than a
quarter a quarter of metal if they're
made of cotton is the cotton less a
dollar bill is it worth less than a
quarter because the quarter is made of
metal like real value oh the actual
melts yeah yeah there's no well hold on
i don't know though you can you can wipe
your ass with money that's
true although are there nickels that are
made of people do you see how much well
in venezuela
yeah so like in venezuela it's funny
when people say things like in weimar
germany they were shuffling money into
like the drains and stuff and i'm like
that's toilet paper man yeah like i'm
you think i'm kidding i'm not kidding
yeah no you gotta you're gonna go buy
toilet paper legitimately my dad i was
talking to him the other day that he
doesn't use toilet paper in russia
something i said something about the
ruble and then he was like yeah the only
use for the ruble is if you need
wallpaper right now oh wow wallpaper or
what a toilet paper wallpaper looks like
it's just but i'm thinking like in
venezuela they throw the money in the
trash i guess you wouldn't want to take
that really filthy money and put it on
your on your whole you know what i mean
because you like you get sick or
something this is that a nickel is 75
percent copper and 25 nickel i mean
that's a little misleading to call it
well i think they used to be nickel but
then i think that did that but nickel i
don't know if you saw what happened this
week with all the war stuff and all the
nickel comes from russia or like a huge
amount and then it was like all these
like commodity companies basically are
i've gone like bankrupt because nickel
i think it went up a hundred percent in
a day two days in a row
wow i should have bought nickels yeah
and then the
the exchange cancelled a lot of the
orders they straight up canceled them
they're like what was it wasn't it it
isn't but it's not really nickel it was
silver right
nickel is copper 75 percent i mean
originally like when they were get when
the nickels were in circulation yeah
originally like the dot like i know like
the dimes and stuff i don't know and i
don't know if in america but probably
but they were literally so you can you
could buy you can buy bags of loose
change that's measured in silver weight
not denomination so if you go to these
like metal websites yeah yeah you get a
bag of you know pre-1960s coins whatever
it's all silver yeah they're all silver
the price of nickels doubled in the last
week yeah they went from point eight i
don't know how to measure this but it's
doubled that's the precious metals are
all going up because of the
because russia that's a big produces a
ton of them if your net wealth is a
nickel you just doubled your net wealth
but there's a lot of there's a lot of
one wasn't sitting there banking
one day but there's a lot of nickel
producers who were like i guess they had
hedged their production
and then this is like essentially
because this is such an unnatural like
movement in the price that it was like a
bunch of them got bankrupted like they
essentially just like right
i don't know the exact thing but so then
they had to there's companies like
bailing them out now because you can't
just like take this nickel production
offline geez
nickels are worth more than dimes no
then then they're then themselves i mean
pennies are worth more than a penny but
it's illegal to melt them well i think
pennies are zinc or something
yeah but like the the inflation is is so
rapid now i just googled it this could
be outdated but it says jefferson
westward journey nickels 2004 2005. 75
copper their value is 6.7 cents yeah so
that means inflation was so high i just
gave you 400 bucks and you just gave me
back 300 bucks yeah same thing dude
looking at the cost of nickel over the
last 10 years it's sitting here at
points point five point five for no it's
like a straight line and then it goes
yeah literally straight line
well i was reading some articles today
they were telling you that inflation's
actually pretty good and it mostly only
hurts rich people yeah yeah yeah i saw
that too all right it's exciting those
are my favorite takes yes i love those
takes but it's actually it's bad for
only rich people and you
you know it's funny because i would even
say as
like
when people talk about the gas prices on
this like you know how stephen colbert
was kind of out there being like you
know i don't know if you talked about
this but stephen colbert's take was like
you know awesome yeah we do we care if
it's higher right but i would agree i
don't see
you know normal fluctuations like i
wouldn't you know make much changes
based on gas prices and i'm not but for
someone uh
for anyone to say that like inflation
and that affects exclusively rich people
you go it takes a lot of mental
gymnastics to get there well you know
look i can i can absolutely respect that
regular people are impacted but
to colbert's defense you know people
like us
it's very difficult for us to track the
cost of gas because when we ask winston
to go fill up our bets
we don't actually see the gas station
prices
and so he comes back and just it's taken
care of and then we have a financial guy
who takes care of as you drive by go
winston what are those numbers on that
sign well that's what i said oh yeah can
you get me a bag or a cup of gas or
whatever
blah blah blah something something yeah
how much is this one guess yeah i got a
couple guys how much you need a couple
grand or was it gonna cost and then no
but like winston walks up and you're
like what do you need to develop the car
like two three thousand he goes uh one
hundred dollars because it's only a
hundred you hand him a hundred dollar
bill and yeah you know you don't realize
that he goes it's eight a gallon or
whatever i go
under a gallon is that high is that low
100. that low
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in monday through friday at 8 pm
and if you want more special access
content head over to timcast.com and
become a member your membership helps
sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there
you